foreign
the iconic 1000 true fans the most
popular thing you've ever written right
why do you think
that is the case and what would you
double down on or revise if you were to
take another
stab right at it today
the honest answer one of the reasons why
it's right
let me talk about when we bought why
it's good and useful and then why it's
popular the reason why it's popular is
actually through you
the fact that you included it in one of
your books and that's sort of lifted it
out of my little Realm
the reason why maybe it kind of
resonates with people
is because there is sort of a an
assumption
that
the goal is to hit it big The Big Time
Best Seller a hit and most people kind
of come to associate that those numbers
that kind of large scale with success
the idea that success could look
differently that you could have a more
modest size
scale and that be successful
sometimes it's dismissed as lifestyle
businesses or whatever and
I kind of realize that the technology
would allow a different version of that
it was possible and that it would be
good it would be good for people and so
that was I think people can resonate
with that because it's
it's a viable alternative option to
things that was not
spoken before was not even really on the
radar and when I wrote it when I first
wrote it before you even saw it there
was no Kickstarter there was no Patron
and I was challenged with people like
Journal near
to say you know that's a nice Theory but
there isn't any evidence that this is
actually working
and it was actually at that time I did a
follow through and I tried to find
evidence and there was there was
evidence of established artists
from publishing or music or Studios who
had already an audience and could move
off of that to their own
but there wasn't any evidence of an
indigenous
organic growth from nothing
now there is every day people write to
me and meet me say yes I have been able
to do that
inspired someone by hearing of that
possibility
is there anything that you would modify
in that piece
or emphasize more so I did a
modification for you which was I talked
about the fact that one again one
benefit and one disadvantage the one
benefit is is that
part of what we're doing is
for all you need is a thousand true fans
then even if your interests are one in a
million
given the population of the Earth
of billions of people that means there's
a thousand people potentially
on the planet who will share your
interests if your interests are only one
in a million people
that you still have enough
and then the second thing was that just
emphasize to people that
this is not for everybody that tending
the fans and interacting with them
is almost like a halftime job at least
maybe even more and not everybody's
suited to do that an artist might just
want to paint they don't want to deal
with fans and we see more of dealing
with fans what it means is it's not
always pretty and it can burn you out
and so I just want to emphasize that
this is an option and you don't have to
go all the way you can have your
thousand true fans and then you can have
lots of other casual fans and other fans
which would allow you to have other
people help you so it's not just you and
then secondly for some people you want
to have intermediaries it's just not
something you want to spend your time
doing and that's perfectly fine but it's
a really great place to be able to start
from
so maybe you don't want to land there
but that's one of my pieces of advice is
that where you start it's not where
you're going to land so you this is a
good place to start that's exactly what
I was going to say which is even if you
want to hypothetically build a huge
company and change the world although
I'm very skeptical of people who lead
with that
I think most businesses fundamentally
are lifestyle businesses if you really
double click and look at it closely
enough even if someone aims to be a
Fortune 500 CEO in any case the point I
want to make is even if you have these
very lofty
large-scale goals beginning with the
exercise of reading 1000 true fans
and at least considering what your
approach would be to accomplish that
first is a great yeah fundamental step
and partly that is because you get a
thousand two fans by accumulating them
one by one and if you're focused on like
today I'm gonna get one more additional
customer
that is tremendously powerful you know
customer by customer are they happy am I
giving value to them
you know if you can focus on that that
is incredibly a superpower yeah for sure
and if you can take those 1000 tree fans
in right and some subset of them become
your PR slash marketing forces then
things can multiply very quickly